hey guys I'm Ryan right so today we're
gonna do another challenge from Nick's
turvy impossible challenge try not to
laugh or grin while watching this weight
or grin yeah you have to be completely
emotionless I'm already smiling because
I'm so charming that I naturally smile
but we're gonna do this and that
background noise you're hearing it's the
AC because we just did a video where I
was sweating like crazy so and so is she
and it wasn't Pleasant so let's do this
don't laugh don't smile
you know emotion you must be the empty
cold self that you actually are at heart
that you don't show to people empty
empty your just empty okay alright one
two three
excuse me sir has never been a robbery
at this establishment
okay you need to share sure in the
spirit
oh that is cool he's handsome
that is a grown man
would you do for a Klondike bar
all right I know there was someone
others are just like that was cool that
you know like the $20 bill one I was
like oh why would I laugh regret that
that was [ __ ] impressive his health
but know these challenges that wasn't
the hardest one but there were a couple
that really got me when I kid brokenness
splits I butt
Larry oh man I want to do more of these
actually but they always say like this
is impossible this is so hard
no it was impossible when the guy went
to splits like that one was impossible
that one broke e oh you can't a lot of
people don't know this but I can do the
splits I need to see this cue the video
of me doing the splits here we go
I just heard something pop aha that
people T told you do the splits I know
you didn't see the video but the editing
room will show the audience the video oh
yeah there's that bit know where you
yeah hopefully one day if you actually
decide to watch videos on this channel I
knew you do yeah really did you hear
about this channel before you came on
the channel yeah yeah that's what
everyone says well anyway guys yeah
thanks for the challenge if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Alana's
channel it's great channel check it out
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine because if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement and let's do a shout out
Phil Scarpa hello to you Ryan and the
other reactors this will be my first
time asking a shout out of anyone as for
you and your channel I find it quite
elin that's unlike the fancy word for it
has high school dropout I watch trailers
for a little bit I don't know and very
spectacular just keep doing what you're
doing - you'll be famous in no time well
I do have over 180,000 fans
i mean--you it it's a little famous than
you think
as for me I'll be no to the whole world
eventually be known to the whole world
eventually my own name will reach up to
the heavens
thanks PS please give me a shout-out
Phil Scarpa let's see what you look like
buddy let's see if you're worthy of
being famous based off your looks he
just graduated something looks like a
high school grad
you're in college man do you know what
that means
[ __ ] up the roof you're gonna have a
good time my friend I'm telling you
girls in college easiest poonanny to get
nothing easier than that I want to come
back for this I'm telling you right now
like Ilana what some advice you would
give to a college kid in order to you
know don't give some girls I would say
go to a lot of parties I didn't I didn't
do that my my college days I just
graduated by the way go to a lot of
parties okay
you'll meet some girls there and I'd
advise if people are partaking in drugs
they are drinking alcohol marijuana
cocaine LSD ecstasy heroin any kind of
speed just really participate it's and
and and and you know like every guy
knows make sure the girl does more than
you that way she'll regret it in the
morning when she wakes up next to you
okay Phil how could you regret wait him
I think a lot of people would